richie trabajo tres cuartos de hora por
dos días en su proyecto de ciencias
kyle trabajo un cuarto de hora por seis
días en su proyecto de ciencias quien
tardó más tiempo en hacer el proyecto
entonces queremos saber quién tardó más
tiempo en hacer el proyecto y para hacer
eso sería bueno saber cuánto tiempo
tardó cada uno tanto richie como kyle en
su trabajo de ciencias así que qué te
parece si empezamos con ritchie y lo voy
a escribir aquí rich y bueno el uso tres
cuartos de hora lo voy a contar aquí
tres cuartos de hora por dos días
entonces tenemos tres cuartos
dos días dos por tres cuartos o también
lo podemos ver de la siguiente manera
podemos decir que el trabajo tres
cuartos de hora el primer día y el
segundo día trabajo otros tres cuartos
de hora así que tres cuartos de hora más
otros tres cuartos de hora nos da un
total de seis cuartos seis cuartos de
hora lo que el gasto en su proyecto de
ciencias ahora pensemos en caer y lo voy
a escribir aquí vamos a hablar de kyle y
si recuerdas aquí en el problema dice
que el trabajo un cuarto de hora lo voy
a notar aquí un cuarto de hora por seis
días
por seis días o seis por un cuarto y
bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo que
decir que el trabajo un cuarto de hora
el primer día más otro cuarto de hora el
segundo día más otro cuarto de hora
déjame ponerlo bien otro cuarto de hora
el tercer día más otro cuarto de hora el
cuarto día más otro cuarto de hora el
quinto día y por último el sexto día
también trabajo otro cuarto de hora el
trabajo seis veces una dos tres cuatro
cinco seis seis veces un cuarto de hora
y entonces esto nos da un total de seis
cuartos de hora o lo que es lo mismo
kyle gastón seis cuartos de hora de su
tiempo para hacer su proyecto de
ciencias y ahora que ya sabemos cuánto
tiempo tarda cada uno entonces podemos
regresar a la pregunta y la pregunta
decía quién
con más tiempo en hacer el proyecto fue
rich y que trabajó seis cuartos de hora
para el que trabajó seis cuartos de hora
y la respuesta obviamente es que
trabajaron el mismo tiempo el mismo
tiempo trabajaron kyle y richie en su
proyecto de ciencias y esta es la
respuesta